huh 400 and [ __ ] 30 000 [ __ ]
dollars in one [ __ ] month no no no
this could be explained was it was sort
of Controlled Chaos it was very
calculated chaos and he wanted it to be
like that specifically he wanted all the
actors to have a loose sort of feeling
in their performance and we improvise a
tremendous amount beforehand with all
the actors
then Marty would kind of restructure the
scenes and then we'd go in again on the
day and then tear that entire scene
apart and you quoted all the [ __ ]
sides tell them about the sides what the
coolest thing about Martin Scorsese ever
is he just loves to see what you're
gonna do he enjoys it so we'd be
improvising and I'd be thinking in my
head I probably sound like an idiot
right now I must be saying something
really stupid and then I'd hear Mighty
laugh and then I'm like oh no I'm on the
right track it's good what are these
signs that cure cancer the sides did
cure cancer that's the problem it was
really an editing nightmare I think for
for Marty and Thelma because they had
hours and hours and hours and hours of
Improv